okay I think this is the first time
myself
and the rabbit are playing let's go with
the bird the bird is the word
last time I played the birds opening I
felt I felt the the need to go with the
birds opening who was here for that
stream Bishop b2 let's get on this
diagonal and Knight f3 let's go
is that Knight can have a better Square
and III so far so the same actually this
is the same situation as that game I
played in the last stream two days ago
and I said sometimes that I don't think
in that game but I've said it before in
this opening sometimes white will want
to voluntarily capture this night and
now you know black is telling me what to
do
so I'm gonna do it okay with that here's
the plan the big plan at this point is
to restrict the light square bishop I
think it's already a critical position
for black and I don't know that that's
the correct move just a quick thought
right here I think the best move in that
position right here instead of Bishop e7
is of all things actually I'm not going
to tell you the answer not gonna tell
you the answer that one I'm going to let
you try and figure it out so take a
quick snapshot of this position where
the bishop visualize it on f8 what do
you think the best move is in this
position see what you could come up with
and then I'll voice my own thoughts I
don't want to give away stuff right away
you subject your own thoughts I think
that could help to improve your game so
let's go with C for now what was that
move that black maybe maybe should have
been playing right there and I I I feel
pretty strongly about it to be honest so
and I'll talk about that after the game
so I'm kind of peaking over there in the
chat as this game is going on to see if
the move is being referenced is it being
referenced
we can see - because I want to play e4
and I want to be in a position to I
think capture in this direction should
this capture come about do I have the
majority of you wondering what is this
big bad move that he's suggesting
instead of there should be seven but
wait a second
maybe my queen has second thoughts and
maybe it's actually okay that she's
having to take a second turn and come to
the e2 square maybe maybe I'm not
comfortable with things after all Bishop
here
excu got really weird really really
weird
actually my in some trouble here pawn
push or queen out here I don't I do not
like right now that my queen is tethered
to this III pun the first moment I have
I'm playing here and saying get out of
there Knight
although there is a problem with that
isn't there may be a bishop check or
something now this is absolutely
collapsing my opponent is making good
moves here they are doing well to to
take advantage of that silly Queen move
I'm seeing I'm learning something more
about the structure now because of how I
was playing the center has officially
opened up and guess what that is exactly
what I do not want to have happen
because this bishop is gonna kill me I
was saying right from the beginning as
soon as this structure came about that I
want to restrict this bishop well I can
throw that one right out the window
because he is ready to come out here
maybe here uh however can I actually
throw this move in does that work Age 3
and then take okay so wait a second do I
have something this actually might work
no no no no no no no no no oh is this
gonna get scary
prepare yourself it's gonna get very
scary if there's a bishop check I'm
gonna move my King to f1 Wow scary time
and if the knight place to f2 I'm gonna
play rook here okay so this is the
variation we're working with our wing
interesting so I'm also down on time
didn't realize and that's uh it's not a
good position of being take here
let's do this first oh I'm also down at
time hmm
can I just take here right away Bishop
takes Bishop Queen takes Bishop Knight
takes pawn and then King here that is
really scary I'm gonna go with this
Bishop takes I think is correct or maybe
it's not I might have a sneaky move with
Queen c2 okay I'm out of the woods I
think I'm out of the woods I have a
giant group of pawns right here giant
group okay things are actually okay now
the smoke has cleared there is no more
tension with regard to the punch the
pawn structure Bishop check just get out
of here now the Queen is constrained
she's tethered to this Bishop Queen
right here is a serious threat so I
think the bishop runs into trouble
well pawn push here I'm getting that
Bishop all right Queen here
I like wow maybe centralize my night
yeah let me just do that there's a oh
there's Bishop takes G he's my opponent
gonna see it he's my opponent listening
don't you dare listen if you take here
you're listening less than 30 okay let's
go Queen I'm going to attack now there's
a queen check but I think that should be
alright let's open this up there's still
a queen check you guys should be playing
King here now my queen could block take
the pawn you're dead dead meat okay
let's let's defend where's the time
where's the time 22 tikka Rooskies the
queens are off there's very little fear
for my king they should be fearing the
worst here we go opposite colored Bishop
ending but I'm up boss and material is
the jeep I'm gonna move here's the plan
rook g1 pawn push but the bishops gonna
play here
get out of there bishop what do I want
to do I want to go after the c5 pawn
very quick come on quick quick quick
look wait 14 seconds is not a lot I'm a
dead man
can I get this Brook Effie you know you
want to do it look f8 oh it's very scary
10 seconds I don't know what I did leave
myself any time no time to win it I'm so
dead why are they giving me that why are
they giving me that King position and
then Bishop here 7 seconds no time
skewers and then trade somehow oh they
should've went with the other one clock
situation for I should have got the rook
should have given a check ok I could get
this now three point five is actually
enough it's actually enough here okay
cut that King off and see where it's
gonna go okay now I have that actually
push push push push
I hear right here and then right there
coming up next I don't know what did I
do I let the king out how do you let the
king out how do I live the King out I
thought it was me what just happened
there I thought I had a stepladder
what happened wait a second I thought it
oh I didn't have the King cut off I was
thinking the rook had the king cut off
uh-huh
oh I thought he had like x-ray vision
apparently he doesn't have that oh man
seeing things that are not there good
game let's back up I should up on that
okay right here let me get back to it
right here this is the thing that it was
I not you know this is the thing I was
not voicing in her hair I didn't want to
spill the beans on this move but I think
now I did not play it right without it
this night move I really have to give
this more weight because that got to be
very hairy right there but anyhow I
think instead of the bishop move I think
it's important to play a five and I
don't know I won't be able to scroll up
all the way for those that were picking
what move I was you know getting out
there actually is it no it's too far up
so look there to see it but anyhow I
think a five with the following
intention a four to break at this
structure and allow the bishop to play
to a six and I think it comes I think
it's time sensitive because otherwise
and this is what I should have been
doing
I think c4 is still fine after castle
Queen here Queen e2 if a five then I
could play Knight c3 to a four I think
if black plays a five first however a
five then I play what if I play C four
then there's a four and if I play Knight
c3 well then now I can't get my knight
in to this to the c3 square or excuse me
if if a five is played I need to stop
this a four break so and if I'm playing
Knight c3 my C pond isn't contributing
just yet so it would run something like
this a five-night c3 I'm trying to get
in this is what I'm trying to get I'm
trying to get in Knight a four and then
c4 to restrict this Bishop however after
a five-night c3 Bishop a six as soon as
i play my Knight to a4
there's a couple things black consider
doing one play Bishop b5 to attack my
knight and to simply place c4 and black
is officially striking at my white pawn
structure and in doing so breaking our
eliminating one of their doubled pawns
this is very time-sensitive right here
a5 Knight c3 Bishop a six-night a4 and
there you go Bishop b5 is available or
c4
if after Bishop e7 now I get in c4 I do
play that in the game and if a 5 right
now I could play Knight c3 if Bishop a6
I play Knight a4 and in that instance
there is no Bishop b5 because my pond is
on c4 in time and because it is on c4 in
time there is also no possibility for of
course black to be playing see for
themselves so anyhow it didn't really uh
I mean my opponent broke things down but
if I had to do it over I would not be
playing Queen c2 but rather Queen e2
with again this intention of Knight c3
to a4 piling up on this c5 pawn
essentially I was too concerned about by
the way if you're wondering why I played
Queen c2 I was I wanted to be in a
position to meet D take C with D take C
and have my Queen watch over this square
I didn't want the night to play here but
I guess I can always take him out by
challenging at them by challenging him
with let's say my night on d2 or maybe
later after the night plays here come
over with this Queen c2 move but anyhow
those were some of my earlier thoughts
it definitely got really wacky and I
think there was an opportunity right
here actually for what a bishop takes a
g4 move was available right here after I
play my knight here this pawn is now
overloaded needing to watch both knight
in pond when you have your opponent in
that sort of position look for tricks
look for tactics and I believe that
Bishop takes right there would be a
decent tactic
to run with the bishop check I would shy
away from that I think you end up
running into some trouble
I don't really if the intention with the
bishop move was to keep me castled
actually me to keep me on castled well
you're successful in doing just that but
then again I don't really intend on
castling my rook is exactly where it
wants to be and you're just kind of
helping my me out and tying your pieces
up now your queen being the one that's
tied up so got really crazy and I really
shouldn't have won like that I think
keeping one piece on the board a rook
keep keeping me guessing and then that's
it you can always throw in some time
burner and I'm toast